تذهب الى عملك محلقا في السماء تطير
معانقا السحاب في طريقك الى جامعتك او
للقاء الاصدقاء مثلا
سيناريو كان حلما او ربما يقتصر على افلام
الخيال العلمي لكن لحلم بدء تدريجيا
بالتحول الى حقيقه فالسماء ستاخذ مكان
الاسفلت في المواصلات المستقبل
[موسيقى]
عام 2019 ظهرت في ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه
سياره من انتاج شركه هولنديه تمتلك مراوح
تسحب عندما يقرر السائق الطيران فيها
قدرتها على التحليق في الهواء بسرعه 200
ملم في الساعه والسير على الارض بسرعه 100
مل في الساعه جعلتها محطه انظار كثيرين
حول العالم
[موسيقى]
سياره فلاي اند درايف تتسع شخصين وتتحول
من سياره ذات ثلاثه عجلات لسياره طائره في
غضون عشر دقائق فقط تقطع 60 ميلا في اقل
من ثمان ثوان ومالكها سيحتاج لرخصه قياده
ورخصه طيران في ان معنا
السياره الهولنديه الطائره كانت اول مركبه
تطير تحصل على ترخيص في اوروبا ثم اتت من
بعدها السياره السلوفاكيا الخارقه
المعروفه باسم اركار لتحصل احد ايضا على
ترخيص يثبت صلاحيتها للطيران في دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي هذه السياره من انتاج
شركه كلاين ما يميزها انها شبيهه الى حد
كبير بالسيارات العاديه هنا تسير على
الارض ثم وفي ثوان معدوده تعدل من وضعيه
اجنحتها لتطير في السماء
وافقت هيئه النقل لسلوفاكيه على منح هذا
الترخيص الفريد من نوعه بعد اختبار
السياره الطائره لمده 70 ساعه طيران و200
عمليه هبوط واقلاع واظهر الثبات المذهرا
ودينامكيا في وضعها كطائره
اما في روسيا فطور علماء دراجه طائره من
اربع عجلات تتسع لشخص واحد ويمكنها السير
ثم التحليق في الهواء لبضعه كيلومترات
في صناعه السيارات الدخول لعالم السيارات
الطائره مؤكده ان الطيران بسيارتها بات
قريبا جدا خاصه بعد اختبار نموذج اولي
يشبه الطائرات من دون طيار
العلم والتطور التكنولوجي بدا يهيئان لوضع
جديد في عالم التنقلات والمواصلات نماذج
السيارات الطائره اصبحت كثيره وجميعها في
طور التحديث والتطوير وحلم الركوب بطائرتك
الشخصيه والتنقل بها اينما تريد اصبح
قريبا
[موسيقى]
لكن رغم ذلك تطوير المركبات الطائره وحدها
لا يعد كافيا فهناك امور كثيره اخرى يتوجب
تنظيمها قبل اتاحه هذا النوع من وسائل
النقل الشخصيه خصوصا عمليات الاقلاع
والهبوط اضافه الى احتمالات الاعطال
والحوادث في السماء وغيرها الكثير فهل
تجدون ان من السهوله اعتماد هذا النوع من
المركبات للتنقل الشخصي